Practice, perseverance, and passion.
These are key elements of my success.
But you may ask whether did I achieve,...
...accomplish my dream to become the world's number one in ultimate competition?
And I have to say, no, I did not...
...but, I did challenge all the top grandmasters,...
...I played in the world championship tournaments...
...and I did beat 11 respected world champions.
After those championships, tournaments, challenges, fights, victories,...
...I have a new dream.
My dream is to see educational chess in all elementary schools...
...because I strongly believe that chess is not only a game, sport and part of culture,...
...but it is an essential educational tool.
I was very fortunate when I was very little to learn the game of chess.
It gave me a lot of success,...
...happiness over the chessboard,...
...but it gave me much more.
It gave me life skills which I use in everyday life whatever I do.
In our multitasking world, I think creativity, logical thinking,...
...problem solving and good decision making are essential skills.
But until my new dream becomes reality,...
...I like to inspire people especially youngsters to dream big,...
...make good moves in life,...
...set your goals high and reach the impossible.
Thank you.